How's it going, bros
It's me
PewDiePie
And I were you money made come on I
Look like a penis who wears this on ironically how much should I spend on this now? I'm ready to rob a bank
The Gucci bank what?
Look why everybody, you know if past PewDiePie could see himself now he would be so proud
Oh, my god is worse without it
Ok
Enough about the mask. Alright, my Matt my face is warm. I love it. I absolutely love it
Thank you Gucci for sponsoring this video. Well, let's begin why leave your
I
Made him laugh. We're making progress
Stop this meme needs to stop it ends here. Ok, cuz I'm not giving you any reaction
You had your fun now?
Leave this Alex Vause guy celebrated article 13. Let's make a meme out of him
It's cool that I get to I get to see the same memes that I posted myself, but by you guys good job
Good job. I feel like now that memes are banned
Yeah
That's the real reason. I gotta wear this hood. No one can know my identity
Alright memes are illegal. Now. The man behind Eve's copyright law is surprised by what's in the proposal
What they're French? I didn't know that this was in the proposed so so far
So, of course I have to deal with it now. Yeah, you deal with it Alex. Look at me Alex you
So engagement you have been living under a rock EU ban means and this guy apparently didn't even know what he voted for
Can someone remind him that's right when I hit?
500,000 subscribers I will lick
My I never said this I never said this but I will however do it anyway because I always keep a promise
Can you physically do it listen I'm not gonna do it
I just want to know if you can refine if peopIe from the past tune in now, he would be very proud
He's judging me. Shut up. Hey, look, it's another meme. I've already showed in a video because I saw it elsewhere
Alright honestly, like I said
I wanted to do the green screen so that you guys could just post ironic
Reaction memes but it seems like everyone just wanted a green screen thing
so I'll link a new green screen competition where I'll do some actual moves and say some things instead of me awkwardly just going
Which apparently means something else?
Final attempt to get pewds and Mertz to see my drawing that's amazing. Maybe draw me next time. What are you doing?
Well, this is actually
Epic fortnight has now been sighted in more than 200 divorce proceedings. This is epic
Can we hit 500 divorce proceedings? This thing is itchy as hell. Oh great. It's another meme from duck
Well done duckling. Well done. Good joke good mean
I'm honestly surprised is this 200 if like an emergency I played fortnight the weddings would just instantly be canceled
Okay, here we go
Using the drink format using the new improved poppy Harlow version this is what I'm talking about
Render me. Daddy. Ill I love the bottle one somewhat. Let me show you guys
Hey, I just love this reaction so much it took me so many attempts to get it right. Come on
It's the god-like reaction. You're not gonna get anything more than that. No one used state. This is a complete failure
this however, that's epic did Brad just
Because of the Hurricanes
Hmm, no museums in the future. When are you guys gonna let it go? I'm trying to rebuild my reputation
Okay, so stop, please stop referencing like it or hate it. That's history right there
Welcome to 2018 a picture of a young man
Holding hands with this apparent girlfriend while looking and whistling at another woman walking by
The seemingly irritated girlfriend is labeled Internet censorship
that's the
Internet community and the other woman and provide solution. Hey, you know what?
This is not bad when the band memes I can still enjoy memes
We figured it out boys, you know what for a bunch of nine-year-olds
You guys aren't that dumb slightly more entertaining than the actual me
We're gonna die in a gulag, but man, it'll be worth it
It's funny cuz it's true
Absolute man lads absolute insane lads. Wait, that's a thing my face is so hot. I hate this
Okay, wait, yeah well vanish dog
That's standish dog. Hey, look at that as mean still kickin it. Good job. Good job everyone today
I saw an Indian guy
Betraying t-series. I think we're winning boys. Yes
This is truly. The only way we can beat t-series by recruiting Indians
If you're an Indian police smash subscribe, we'll take any one dick ahead que
Se dice yacht lane
He said the seat ollie. It's not that hard. Is it the badge means means an honorable nine year old commander?
He leads the Indians
let's ask pues to learn Russian so he could understand Russian memes and
Conquer T series with Russian audience all I understand Russian memes
It's all suit gabion dish and cyka be a dick. Okay, I saw there is to it
Okay, is that pee I in spider-man's costume
Why just because I didn't nail the handshake there's nothing wrong this is discrimination
This is cyberbullying and I will not stand for this Jesus
Look even spider-man can fail this is so relatable
Superhumans are humans too. Super PETA super whatever
I'm so glad I did the whole gift competition because everyone is using it. What a great idea
Hey Felix, we want you to give us more challenges
Ok, here you go Oh f-you Felix 10 or space everybody
Now this is a speed comedy right there. I'm laughing. Ok
That's epic. You know what I take it back. That's actually awesome
Nice one Pano's stam Oh
Amazing if this video gets 400,000 likes I will play like I already played it. Stop crying. You nine-year-old babies. Hey
Hey, look, it's the same mean goddamn. My face is 18
Wait a second. Oh
My god, oh my god. Oh, yeah
Ok, I don't know what I just did we have officially peaked wait I got my
Ass cutie pie to make a 5 minute video
which shall be slowed down to X so it will have 10 minutes and
We as viewers will set playback speed to 2 X
Equals monetize. This is genius. We I will do this
Way, I gotta send this to bride marijuana alcohol
drugs
Telling your daughter about your dominatrix job wearing Gucci
Alright so if I hit 66 million subscribers, I will play a lego star. This is a lie
Why do you guys want me to play Lego so badly Scooby Doo?
Scrappy Doo
Get out the dare
Proof of whom face being beautifies original face nanny
Alright, that was this week's LA
YouTube's favorite show everybody smash like if you enjoyed watching and subscribe so we can beat the Indians
I mean T series, of course and let me know what I should wear in the next episode and I'll see you guys next time
brofist
Awesome great